[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
slowly video game releases are popping
up again after a few
barren months april sees the first month
of 2021 with something for everyone from
rpgs to sports sims
to soccer moms in space and a bunch of
free games too
here's eight games worth your time
throughout april 2021
on april fool's day a new looter shooter
is here to grab your attention
outriders outriders follows in the steps
of destiny and the division and smashes
both ways of playing together
on the surface we use cover and press
forward through countless enemies
to obtain the sweet nectar of loot guns
and gear
scratch beneath the surface to unveil a
class-based shooter
with some mighty impressive superpowers
i made a video about
outriders last month if you need more
info and details about the free portion
of the game
i'll link it now but without a doubt the
ability to slow down time and watch
enemies explode into pieces
never gets old that's the trickster by
the way there's also a pyromancer for
char grilling foes and a tank class for
up close and personal action
if you're looking for a grindy game to
replace destiny or the division
then outriders could be your new jam and
the best thing about it
is there is a free demo to try before
you buy outriders hits on april 1st
on ps4 ps5 xbox and pc
oh and stadia as well and all of which
support cross-platform play
back in the 1990s a 2d platformer series
became a must play game
and now 23 years later the remakes have
landed
this is oddworld soulstorm a quick thing
to note for ups plus subscribers
is that soulstorm will be a free game on
the day and date it releases which is
tuesday april 6th
if you played the original game or the
first remake you'll know exactly what to
expect here but if you're new let me
break it down a little
oddworld is a side-scrolling puzzle
platformer the developers described the
game as 2.9 d
as although our paths are predetermined
and pretty much a straight line
there are ways to break that restriction
and move slightly away from the beaten
path
we play as abe an unlikely hero leading
a slave uprising
and that's the key component abe
attempts to free his people by leading
them through stages
but they can perish and the game goes on
a single wrong step
and poor timmy is no more with well over
a thousand madokans to save will you get
them out unscathed
oddworld soulstorm is released on ps4
ps5 and pc on april 6th
and remember ps plus subscribers can
claim this game for free on ps5 on
release day
[Music]
let's stick with the ps5 for eternal a
third-person shooter with heavy
psychological horror elements
yeah a scary game you've likely seen the
protagonist which many people describe
as a soccer mom this is celine a space
traveler who crash lands on a hostile
alien planet
combat is quick with a focus on dashing
and movement
to create space and a variety of weapons
to switch up gameplay
but here is the hook returnal is a
roguelike outing
each death we suffer causes the cycle to
restart
we relive the crash landing which
brought selena here and retrace our
steps
but with each crash the world changes
new pathways open up
and others close and all the enemy
encounters adapt
and change the narrative lets us piece
together the memories of celine through
horror scenarios so expect a jump scare
or two
returnal is a ps5 exclusive dropping on
april 30th
i know that many people don't have
access to a ps5 so i wanted to make sure
you knew that on april 19th
all playstation owners can download
horizon zero dawn
completely for free no strings attached
at all
no need for ps plus either if you have a
ps4 or a ps5
it's completely free to download and
keep forever
this includes the award winning dlc
which most of us haven't played
so even if you do own horizon zero dawn
be sure to add the complete edition to
your library on april 19th
i'm told the fire claw fight is amazing
and we need to try it
so we may as well do that for free
okay a sports game i'm never sure
whether to include sports games in these
lists as either they repulse you greatly
or you buy the sports title of your
choice every year without hesitation
this is mlb the show 21 and the reason i
bring this
up is due to this being the first time
this sony title has appeared on xbox
it's surreal you'll see an xbox logo and
a playstation ident
on the same game mind blown mlb the show
is the baseball version of other annual
sports titles like 2k or fifa
an ever upgrading concept that becomes
closer to real life each season
there's over 100 ways to swing your bat
this year
the detail is plentiful if you have the
eye to see it
mlb the show 21 arrives on april 20th on
both playstation and xbox consoles
a quick passing note about a free game
which has gone under the radar recently
rogue company a third person team based
shooter from the people
who made paladins and smite as i'm
saying this
tomorrow march 30th the ps5 update goes
live
and gives the game 4k visuals and 120
frames per second of awesomeness
so it could be time to revisit the game
if you've left it dormant the game modes
are as you expect
team death match and bomb planting and
defending but the kicker is each hero
has a different set of abilities and
weapons play well and you'll be rewarded
with cash which is then spent before the
next round begins
rogue company is available right now on
everything from ps4 to xbox to pc to
switch
and i think it's coming to samsung smart
fridges too okay the last one was a lie
[Music]
any star wars fans in the house out of
nowhere
a new star wars game drops on ps4 and
switch
on april 6th star wars republic commando
i played this game in 2005 on pc
and now 16 years later it's re-releasing
by the visuals you can tell this is an
old game
but if you are into the rainbow six
series this should have your attention
a star wars focused tactical team
shooter
it was surprisingly good back then i
wonder how it plays in 2021
hey you do you like rhythm games
featuring children
well you should see a psychiatrist or
alternatively play
love live school idol festival after
school activity that is a mouthful of a
title
and if you're in japan or north america
it's totally free
those of us in europe are left out in
the cold on this one love live blast out
j
pop into your ear holes and asks you to
press buttons to the beats as the
characters dance on stage
the difficulty increases as you improve
note that this may
look like a free game from the outside
but it's the addiction of playing which
eventually forces players to buy more
songs
and before you know it you own 69 j-pop
songs and you're 28
and you live all alone it's a slippery
slope if i haven't put you off enough
you'll be happy to know that love live
is available right now to download for
free
on ps4 so there we have it eight games
you can grab over april 2021
slowly the video game ecosystem is
coming back more games are releasing
each month
and remember there are 10 free games you
can download and play right now on
playstation
which include ratchet and clank until
march 31st
and there's nine indie titles including
subnautica and astrobot
although i personally highly recommend
trying enter the gungeon
it doesn't look like much but believe me
it's worth your time anything take your
fancy this time around
i'm gonna try eternal and soul storm for
me thank you muchly
i'm adam from playstation grenade if
you're still here take this dad joke
what do you call a terminator in
retirement
the exterminator thank you
yeah i i'd click off too it's been a
pleasure i'm adam bye